[موسيقى]
شكرا خالد وطبعا مشاهدينا نستكمل معكم
واحييكم انا ميسون عزام ونستكمل معا هذه
التغطيه وان كان العنوان الرئيسي الان هو
عوده حركه الطيران في الولايات المتحده
بعد ان كانت قد توقفت مشاهدينا نشاهد هذه
الصور المباشره الان ننقلها لكم من احدى
مطارات الولايات المتحده كان هناك تعطل
ملح لكافه رحلات الطيران طبعا كان هناك
همم منع همم لاقلاع الطائرات في كافه
المطارات ولكن بحسب الرئيس الامريكي جو
بادن يمكن للطائرات الهبوط في المطارات
كانت هناك حركه خفيفه نشاهد الان هذه
الطائره والتي تعتبر الطائره الاولى التي
تتحرك داخل مطار في الولايات المتحده
اقلاعا بعد ان كان هناك عطل جمد حركه
الطيران في كافه الولايات الامريكيه تاخير
لرحلات مستمره طبعا كان هناك حديث
بالبدايه من خلال التصريحات همم في
الامريكيه من اداره الطيران الامريكي بان
الطائرات ستعود تدريجيا بدءا من هذه
الساعه 14 توقيت جرينتش السادسه بتوقيت
دبي بتوقيت دبي بالفعل والخامسه بتوقيت
السعوديه وبالفعل كما كان قد اعلن
اما الاعلان الان رسميا عن استئناف حركه
الطائره دعونا مشاهدينا نتحدث مع مراسل
العربيه حسين الطود حول هذا الاعلان
وتفاصيله وان كان قد اتضحت الصوره فيما
يتعلق بالاسباب الرئيسه وراء هذا العطل
التقني الذي تم الاعلان عنه دون الخوض
بالتفاصيل من امام مطار رونالد ريجن معنا
مراسل العربيه حسين الطود حسين تفضل
انا الان داخل مطار رونالدو
همم على الساعه التاسعه بتوقيت واشنطن
الثانيه ظهرا بتوقيت جرينتش كان من
المفترض ان تعود حركه الطيران همم الى
وضعتها الطبيعيه ان تبدا الطائرات
بالاقلاع حتى الان العطل همم غير معروف
وعطر ولكن لا تعرف اسبابه بحسب المسؤولين
الامريكيين وبحسب الرئيس الامريكي طبعا
التحقيقات الجاريه لمعرفه الاسباب ولكن لم
يشار الى اي هجوم من سيدنا ابراهيم همم
حتى الان همم
الطائره المروحيه قال بانه لا يعرف
الاسباب الرئيسيه ولكن طالبه بتحقيق من
حيث انت هل تستطيع ان تتابع مؤشر حركه
الطائرات همم حسين طبعا كنا قد شاهدنا همم
الغاء المشاهدين هنا نعم همم هذه هذه هذا
ما نشاهده هنا ميسون هناك الغاء لعدد كبير
او تاجيل لعدد كبير من ال- اا من الرحلات
الجويه هنا في على الاقل في مطار رونالدين
ودعيني فقط وذكر واشير لان هذا المطار هو
مطار وطني ايت تنطلق منه الرحلات الداخليه
داخل الولايات المتحده هناك بعض الرحلات
نحو كندا والمكسيك ولكن هو ليس هو طارق
كبير
سيكون اكبر واكثر عبد الرحلات علم الغاء
او
المتاخره همم ستكون اكثر بكثير همم لا بد
ان هنا من الاشاره والتفكير بانه في شهر
اكتوبر العام الماضي همم ميسون تعرضت اربع
او خمس مرات في الولايات المتحده لهجوم
همم
وظائف همم
المواقع الالكترونيه الخاصه بها صعبه على
المسافرين الوصول الى الى هذه مواقع ايران
واخرى ميسون
جهه للمطار وزاويه تظهر هذه الطائرات ولكن
فيما يتعلق بما استذكرته الان من حادثه
سابقه استهدفت اربعه مطارات من خلال العطل
بسبب ربما استهداف سيبراني هل نذكر كيف
تعاطف
الحكومه الامريكيه مع تلك الحادثه وهل تم
الاعلان مباشره عن انه في استهداف سيبراني
خارجي بمعنى اخر ارهابي او غيره او لا تم
الطعاطي معها كما هو الحل الان لا تفاصيل
حتى يبدا التحقيق
في ذلك الوقت اساسا هي كانت اربع مطارات
فيما بعد قالوا انها 5 او 6 مطارات لا لم
تكن طبعا بهذا الحجم لا لن لن نذكر بانه
تم الغاء رحله طيران او منع الطائرات من
الاقلاع عن المدارس او تاخير الرحلات بسبب
هذا العطل هي كانت فقط بعد ما عرفنا بذلك
كانت في اربعه الى سته مطارات امريكيه
طبعا هي المطارات الكبرى عندما يتم
استهداف همم البنيه تحتيه المتعلقه
بالطيران السابقون المطارات الكبرى بشكل
رئيسي كما قلت مطار همم اتلانتا مطارات
نيويورك مطار سان فرانسيسكو شيكاغو
المطارات التي تسمى حب يعني
اليوم هنا نعم
حدث في حينها هل تم الاعلان مباشره
بالاعلان عن الاسباب الحقيقيه
همم وراء هذا العطل
الامريكيون حذرون حتى يعني في هكذا امور
لا يرمون التهم مباشره هم يجب ان اا هذه
الطياره اخرى تتحرك الان عاده لا لا همم
لا يصدرون قراراتهم بسرعه او او يواجهون
التهم بسرعه يجب ان يتحققوا كما يجري الان
في ذلك الوقت ايضا لم ااه
يعني يتهم او يوجه الاتهام الى جهه معينه
مباشره وحتى المسؤولين عند اتحدث
ان لا تذكر اسماءهم همم فقالوا ان انه
ربما تكون هذه الهجمات منطلقه همم او
مصدرها همم روسيا بعد الهكر في روسيا ولكن
همم لم يوجهه اصابع اتهامه مباشره الامر
طبعا يحتاج الى تحقيق همم هذا همم يتطلب
همم معرفه تقنيه همم الاي بي ادرس همم
الهجوم همم هناك يعني من الهجمات التي
تتعرض لها البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه في
السنوات همم الماضيه هناك هجوم الهجوم
الذي يستهدف الحواسيب والمواقع بحركه
ويغرقها بحركه كبيره ما يؤدي الى فشلها في
فشل وظائفها همم هذه نوع من الهجمات التي
تتعرض له الان او تتع- سابقا تعرضت له
البنيه التحتيه الالكترونيه الامريكيه في
اكثر من مره
في شهر مارس من العمل 2020 ميسون الرئيس
الامريكي نفسه حذر من احتمال وقوع هجمات
سيبرانيه وطالب الشركات
همم
السحابه الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
امريكيه من قبل الرئيس الامريكي نفسه بانه
الدنيا تحتيه معرضه لهامات صيدليه خاصه
بعد الحرب همم الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
هناك حديث على روسيا تريد ان تبث دع يعني
زئيفه وحذر من هذه الهجمات
دائما اللي هجمتها الالكترونيه وهذا
الحديث عنهم
تم تسريب اسماء كبيره واختراق حسابات
كبيره حسين اذا ما عدنا بالمقارنه ما بين
ما حدث في السابق والان همم قضيه العطل
واسبابه هل هي متشابهه او لا ان كنت تذكر
طبعا يمكن ليس لديك المعلومات متوفره بين
لديك
طبعا همم
الان هذا العطر بان يتم ايقاف جميع
الرحلات الامريكيه في جميع ان تخلو السماء
الامريكيه من جميع طائرات هذا هذا طبعا
امر كبير انا همم اني سمعت به قبل هذا
الوقت ربما هذا حدث في عام 2001 ااه اثناء
هجوم الحادي عشر من سبتمبر همم يتسبب عطل
الفن بهذا بهذا بهذه العرق في حركه
الطائرات على مستوى الاجواء الامريكي عامه
هذا هذا امر همم اعتقد انه امر جديد وامر
يعتبر كبير بالتاكيد في الساعات وفي
الايام همم المقبله سنعرف الاسباب
طالما الان على اعلى مستوى يتم التعامل مع
هذا الموضوع الرئيس الامريكي يتحدث عنه
وكما قلت بانه تقريبا من منذ نحوي عام كان
حذر من امكانيه وقوع هذا هجمات سيبينيه
الان هو كان هناك تحفظ همم من المسؤولين
الامريكيين ولا راسهم الرئيس اصابع
الاتهام او يقول ان هذا العطر هو سبب بسبب
هجوم سيفراني ولكن هذا عطل غريب في
الحقيقه لم اسمعه به قبل الان بان عطل فني
في اجهزه الكمبيوتر ادى الى توقف جميع
حركات الطائره في السماء
المتحده فقط ولكن في الخارج واما
بالولايات المتحده بحسب المعلومات الاخيره
فقط تم تاجيل 4000 الاف رحله وايضا الغاء
750 ابقى معي حسين اعود اليك بعد قليل ان
كان هناك اي معلومات جديده وتصريحات جديده
ينضم الي من تورنتو الكابتن الطيار احمد
العجارمه وهو خبير طيران اهلا بك كابتن
طيار اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءه في همم
التوقعات كان هناك توقعات هناك خلل ولكن
كان هناك معرفه
بالتوقيت التي يتم فيها اعاده احياء حركه
الطيران في كافه الطيران وان كان القول
الان بانه تدريجي بصوره او باخرى وبالتالي
السؤال هنا هل هذا امر
ايجابي بمعنى اخر انهم يعرفون العطل
ويعرفون الحال وبالتالي كل شيء كان تحت
السيطره او لا
مساء الخير بالنسبه لما حدث وبدات قبل
يمكن 4 او 5 ساعات في مطار امريكا طبعا هو
كان شلل جزئي بدايه
بدا من بعض المطارات من مطار
رئيسي تقريبا في امريكا واا انتقل من
شرق امريكا بدايه انتشارا للمطارات في غرب
امريكا هو اعطال فنيه بس بما انه همم اندر
كونترول وحددوا المشاكل
او صرحوا بانه لا يوجد اي هجوم سبراني
لذلك هي اللي بتكون همم
يعني همم كنترول اعاده العمل المطارات
ستكون جاريه لمعرفه الاسباب وراء العطر
وان كان قد عرفوا ما هو العطل واستطاعه
واصلاحه بالوقت المناسب وبالتالي هل يمكن
استبعاد كليا قضيه الاستهداف استمراني او
لا
هو مبدايا مستبعده مبدئيا بس في امريكا
عاده دوله عظمى يعني ما بتركوا اي خطا زي
هيك حتى ما يتكرر مره ثانيه
يعني هذه الكلمه سؤال كبير دوله عظمى
وتسابق تكنولوجيا وغيرها هل يمكن ان تقع
بمثل هذا الخطا اليس هناك من بدائل همم
بالنسبه همم لمثل هذه المشكله التقنيه
ايقاف الرحلات لم يكن همم خلل كامل او شلل
في امريكا هو خلل او شلل في بعض المطارات
بس هو ال- همم باسباب السلامه العامه
للطيران تحكي عن حوالي 10 الاف رحله
باليوم في امريكا همم
للمزيد من السلامه يوقفوا الرحلات اللي هي
كانت المشكله بدات في بعض المعلومات وليس
في كل المطارات لذلك همم عندما تحدث اي
مشكله همم لتامين السلامه للمسافرين
والركاب
العمل في كل الاجهزه في كل المطارات الحين
تحديد الاسباب
ما ذكره مراسل العربيه قبل قليل يلعب ما
حدث سابقا كان هناك همم استهداف وكان
وقتها سيبراني لاربع مطارات ولكن رغم ذلك
الا ان باقي الولايات لم تتاثر ابدا
وبالتالي السؤال هنا لماذا هذه المره اراد
السلامه للطائرات ولم يطبق ذلك في السابق
هاي اللي بتعزز فرضيه انه الخلل الفني
وليس هجوم سبراني هجوم سبران عاده بيكون
على تبعنا انا ما عندي معلومات كيف يعني
همم
اكثر المطار الشغل
لكن لما يكون الخلل
حسب توقع من الاجهزه الكمبيوتر يعني خلال
الفني لذلك بيكون همم العطر همم
امريكا يعني بالمنطقه الشرقيه بدا بدا لما
كان همم
لذلك كان يتزايد يعني قبل اربع ساعات
الحاله كابتن طيار عندما نتحدث ان الطائره
غير قادره على الاقلاع ولكنها قادره على
الهبوط كيف تفسر ذلك
هلا همم هي اللي تخفيف الضغط على الحركه
الجويه الطائرات اللي في الجو يعني
طبعا بدهم ينزلوها لازم كاميرا حلاتها
لذلك عندهم عمله معدله 10 يوميا لما
يخبطوها او اوقفوا الرحلات المغادره هم
خففوا يعني اكثر من 50% من العمل بس
اجراءات السلامه
الطائر اللي في الجوله لازم تنزل يعني ما
في امكانيه عندهم
يوقفوها او يحاولوا على دوله ثانيه مثلا
لذلك لتخفيف الضغط على الاجهزه وعلى
الكادر البشري لانه كثير من المطارات
بتصير الشغل فيها شبه مانيوال يعني شبه
انه بدون احتمال على التكنولوجيا او
الاعتماد جوسي يعني تكنولوجيا
لعمليه استمراريه للحركه حتى يتم اصلاح
الجهاز الرئيسي ما في بديل
عاده هاي اجهزه كمبيوتر شبكات ما اتوقع في
بدائل اييه انه مثلا كل منطقه بتكون
منفصله عن الثاني بالشغل بس لما يكون
المركز الرئيسي اللي هو مطاره فرنسا ذا
بيزنس هذا في امريكا اكبر مطار في شغل
لانه هذا بيطلع من الطائره يعني ترانزيت
معظم يجيء هناك وهو اللي بيطلع لكل الولاء
تقريبا او معظم الرحلات تطلع منه لذلك ما
دام تاثرت يعني العذر الاكبر في هذه
المباراه
كانت تاثيره له الجانبي على المطارات
الاخرى اللي اثر انه اوك اوقف وكل
المطارات يعني زي ما بتحكي كيف لما بعيده
فرمته الجهاز او همم الكمبيوتر
في البدايه من اداره الطيران كان تقنيا
بحثا فيه تفاصيل ربما الانسان العادي همم
لن يستطيع ان يفهمها لا اعلم ان كنت بعد
هذا البيان وان كان بالامكان قراءه ما
يمكن ان يكون من عطل قد حدث لهذه
الاستشعارات واشعارات حركه الطيران وان
كان اي نظام في العالم عرضه لمثل هذا
العطل
او اي نظام بالعالم
بيكون الباكر سنه في اكثر من همم يعني
بيعوض في حاله الخلل هلا اذا احنا في وقت
السلام مش وقت حارب لذلك هو الافضل حتى
يتجنب اي مجال خطا امريكي او بالطيران
دائما
ساعه او ساعتين الى تاثيرات اقتصاديه
كبيره الى تاثيرات على العالم طبعا مش بس
على امريكا تقريبا
على الشاشه طبعا نشاهد همم مطار جون كندي
على ما اعتقد هناك طائرات لا زالت حتى
الان جاسمه همم في تكدس للطائرات حركه
خفيفه ربما ستبدا الحركه تدريجيه
لكي تقلع هذه الطائرات طبعا من هناك همم
لا اعلم فيما يتعلق بمطارات اخرى ولكن
بحسب ما نذكر بالصور القديمه السماء كلها
ملء تكون عاده بالطائرات الارقام تتحدث عن
تاجيل 4000 رحله والغاء مع 750 رحله عدد
كبير كابتن طيار تم تاجيله الى اي حد يمكن
له ان يؤثر على حركه الطيران بصوره عامه
وتاثيره ايضا على الدول الاخرى
هلا رحلات
المهجله او الي صار عليها تعديلات
محليه في امريكا امريكا فيها حوالي 45,000
اهليوميه عندها 10 تقريبا 10,000 طائره
4000 انت 40% من من الحركه متوقفه هلا
الاعاده هي بدات تدريجيا من قبل اكثر من
نصف ساعه من مطار اتلانتها من مطار اظن
نيوورك اللي يمكن يكون في واشنطن همم لذلك
بدات هي كامله 100% خلال فوري همم بيكون
زي بدايه تدريجيا للاعاده بس اتوقع اكثر
ولكن ان شاء الله يعني ممكن خلال ساعه
بتكون راجع همم الحركه تماما همم او خلال
ساعتين همم طبعا الى تاثيرات كبيره على
الدول العالم امريكا الجايه تقريبا
الكونكشنز مع زيت همم امريكا الجنوبيه
لكندا همم اوروبا
يا ريت 75% من الطيران العالمي او خليني
نحكي طيران العالمي الى تاثير كبير اي
رحلات جاي من المناطق البعيده من عبر
المحيطات الى تاثير كبير عليها لانه بتكون
اللي في الجو كان طاير اللي كان يعني اقلع
من لندن مثلا او همم قبل ست ساعات المشكله
وانا صارت قبل اربع ساعات لذلك هذا بيكمل
الرحله الباقي بده يتوقف الحين همم اعاده
النظام للفعاليه
لا همم بيكمل امريكي
ساعود اليك بعد قليل الحديث اكثر عن
سيناريوهات الاخرى نحن نتحدث ونركز الان
على انه العطل فني بحث لا استهدافات
خارجيه من اي جهه ولكن دعني انتقل لضيفي
من القاهره دكتور محمد الشهاوي وهو خبير
الامن السيبراني دكتور محمد طبعا حتى الان
ليس هناك من تاكيدات عن السبب الرئيس وراء
العطل وان كان العطل عرف بالنسبه للسلطات
والجهات التقنيه وتم حله وها نحن نعود
تدريجيا لحركه الطيران عن بعد من متابعتك
ماذا تقول
والله تبقى اللي تقرير
والمسؤولين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعلى راسهم الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بيقول انه عطل تقني لكن
هل في عطل تقني وقالوا له السبب قال ما
بعرف
هل يمكن ان نقرا ما بين السطور من خلال
المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان التي تاتينا
من هناك
يعني انواع الحروب الان اختلفت الحروب
التقليديه اصبحت هناك ما يسمى بحروب
المستقبل واللي قال كلمه حروب المستقبل هو
يعني مارك ميلي اا الجنرال ماركيني لرئيس
هيئه الاركان المشتركه للجيش الامريكي
بيقول ان الحرب الان وخاصه الحرب التي
تدور ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا حرب من حروب
المستقبل اي انه تستخدم اسلحه سايبرانيه
بتستخدم يعني هجمات نفسيه وعلشان كده
بنعرف احنا الهجمات السيبيرانيه بانها
مجموعه من الهجمات الالكترونيه بتصيب دوله
او بتصيب بلد باكملها وبيسعى مطلقه تلك
الهجمات الالكترونيه الى الحق الضرر
والاذى واحنا مش شايفين ضرر واذا اكثر من
اللي بيحصل النهارده في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عندما يتم تعليق اكثر 4000 رحله
قويه
ولد دقيقه
هو احنا بنتكلم ان هناك سيناريوهان ان
يكون عطل فني عطل تقني جاء يعني كده وذوت
الاخر هو ان يكون الهجمات السيبانيه اللي
هي بتاخذ العالم الان عايز اقول انها
بتستخدم كل الدول هناك 150,000 هجوم
الكتروني ضد دول خلال السنوات السابقه
منها هجوم كان ضد ايران وتم تعطيل 5.000
جهاز طرد مركزي في مفاعل نتانجا وبالتالي
باقول يعني الهجمات السيبيرانيه هي من
الحروب الحديثه وحروب المستقبل
لها هدف
نعم يا فندم الهدف هو الحق الادب البنا
التحقيق
كان تحت السيطره اذا ما صح التعبير وتم
اصلاحها هل ممكن ان يكون هاوي او اذا ما
صح بانه هذا استهداف سيبراني فلا يمكن له
الا ان يكون وراء دوله
انا بعتقد انه يستهدف كل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كل المطارات اللي موجوده في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا يمكن ان
يكون هاوي او يكون هناك يعني لابد ان تكون
هناك دوله او يعني احنا نعلم ان هناك
مشاكل كثيره الان وان نعلم ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي من تقوم بتمويل
اوكرانيا بكل الاسلحه وخاصه الاسلحه
الحديثه زي زي منظومه الدفاع الجوي
باتريوت وبالتالي هناك روسيا تريد ان هي
تقول نحن موجودين وانا اعتقد لا يمكن ان
يكون بعيد عن هذا السيناريو وهي تريد نحن
موجودين ممكن ان نلحق الاذى والضرر
همم النظم التقنيه وبالمنى التحتيه
الاساسيه لما حركه طيران يتم تعليقها في
كل ارجاء
اعتقد ان هذه اول مره بهذا الحكم الكبير
اعتقد انها حصلت قبل ذلك في 2019 وفي 2020
ولكنها ليس صحيح صحيح هلا طبعا اللي ذكرته
يتناقد مع رؤيه ااا ااا
كابتن طيار ضيفنا همم الذي لا زال معنا
حتى الان لانه يرى انه
الاستهداف كان لبعض المطارات ولكن تم
ايقاف كافه المطارات فقط كخطوه استباقيه
احترازيه ولا لحمايه كافه الطيران على كلن
ابقى معي دكتور محمد اعود اليك لاثاره هذه
النقطه مجددا ولكن مضطره ان انتقل الان
الى ضيفي او بالاحرى الى مراسل العربيه
حسين المتواجد الان في همم احد المطارات
رونال ريجن داخل هذا المطار اللي ينقل لنا
الاجواء احسانا تفضل
تحيه ميسون مره اخرى بالفعل بدانا نرى
حركه الطائرات هنا في المدرج كما تشاهدين
من خلفي الطائرات تتحرك عندما وصلت الى
هنا قبل تقريبا قبل ساعه كانت الطائرات
مصفوفه مرصوصه قرب بعضها البعض الان ان
نشاهد ان هذه الطائرات تتحرك
بعد قليل الى همم الحائط حيث تعرض الشاشه
تعرض ايضا الرحلات التي تم الغائها
والرحلات التي تم تاخيرها العدد ما زال
كبيرا ولكن بدانا همم نشعر نشاهد بان
المسافرين همم
بداوا يتحركون يدخلون الى اماكن حيث
ينطلقون من هناك همم صلاه الانتظار كما
نشاهد امامنا هنا على هذه الشاشه هناك همم
العديد من هذه الرحلات تم الغائها بعد
رحلات ستطير في الوقت المحدد لها وهناك
ايضا التاخيرات همم الموجوده همم طبعا همم
الامريكي اعلنت ان الرحلات ستبدا تدريجيا
وهذه هي النقطه الرئيسيه تم الاعلان عن
استئنافها تدريجيا اي تفاصيل اخرى واي
تصريحات رسميه
حتى الان طبعا اهم التصريحاتيه التي صدرت
عن البيت الابيض من قبل الرئيس الامريكي
جوبيدا ولكن من المتوقع ان نسمع الكثير
الان من التصريحاتها خاصه المتعلقه
بالتحقيقات لمعرفه الاسباب الحقيقيه لهذا
العطل الفني ان كانت هي هو عطل فني طبيعي
او ان هناك همم ربما ان تكون هناك هجوم
اسيبراني طال اجهزه
التي تتحكم بهذه الطريقه
تحدثنا عن الهجوم الذي وقع في شهر اكتوبر
الماضي عندها استهدف هذا الهجوم اربع
مراته وخمس مطارات ولكنه استهدف همم
المواقع التي همم تزود الجمهور
المواعيد باوقات الازدحام واوقات الانتظار
عندها لم يستهدف الهجوم السيبراني انا ذاك
همم الاجهزه التي تتحكم او تتعامل مع حركه
الطيران ومع الاتصالات بين الشركات وبين
الطائرات وبين المدرج لذلك لم نسمه يومها
يتبقى في حركه الطائره الطيران انما الان
ما جرى امر مختلف لهذا سبب كان هناك
كاجراء استباق وتحذيري كان هناك منع
الطائرات من الاقلاع وطبعا كمان ذكر
ضيفاكي الطائرات التي كانت موجوده في
الاجواء سميح لها بالهبوط بطبيعه الحال
لان لا يمكن تستمر بالتحليق لماذا طويل
ولكن الان الوضع بدا يختلف الان همم نعود
مره اخرى هذا طائره اسرعت الان من مطار
ريجن همم
هل ادى الى نوع من الفوضى ان التعاطي مع
هذه الازمه كان منتظم اذا ما صح التعبير
يعني في سيطره على الوضع بيكافه ان واحد
طبعا هذا الامر ميسون يختلف من مطار الى
مطار عندما نتحدث عن مطارات صغيره او
مطارات وطنيه كما تسمى هنا مثل مطار
رونالدين هو مطار صغير مضبوط عندما نتحدث
عن مطارات كبرى مثل مطار اطلنطا واحد واحد
اهم المطارات في الولايات المتحده واكثرها
عملا هنا قد يختلف الامر ولكن لابد هذا من
الاشاره الى اننا نتحدث عن دوله كبرى يعني
منظمه بشكل جيد المطارات عندهم منظمه بشكل
اموري
لانه لا في انتقادات كبيره جدا من اداره
الطيران بالولايات المتحده بصوره عامه
وبالتالي اريد ان اسال عن نبض المسافرين
الى اي حد كان هناك غضب وهمم الى من
يوجهون اصابع الاتهام او المسؤوليه على
الاقل حسين
عندما يكون اي شخص مسافر ويتم تاخير
الطائره او يسمى هو يشعر بالغضب وسيلقي
بالله على الجميع ولكن عندما نشاهد نحن
اذا اردنا نكون موضوعيين انه نشاهد كيف
يتم التعامل مع هذا الموضوع همم موضوع
التاخيرات وموضوع همم اعطال الكبرى وكما
شاهدنا في هذه طائره اخرى
اذا كنت تشاهدها معي همم عندما هناك يكون
هناك مشكله كبرى نرى ان همم اداره
الطائرات وزاره النقل الامريكيه تتعامل ب
همم بجديه وتعمل باحتراف همم اي موضوع من
هذا النوع همم نذكر بانه هو خلال همم
العاصفه التي ضربت ولايه نيويورك تحديدا
همم بافلو عندما كان هناك مشكله همم في
احدى شركات الطيران همم
اذكر همم تتدخل همم
وكان هناك انتقادات هو كبيره من همم وزاره
النقل اداره الطيران ال- همم فيدراليه
لهذه الشركه لانها تتسببت بتسعين بالمائه
من همم من همم
تعطل الرحلات في عيد الميلاد وراس السنه
همم عندما يكون الاطار يعني يعني
الشركه هي نفسها
الرئيسيه يدفعني للحديث عن قضيه العلاقه
ما بين الشركات الخاصه واداره الطيران
الفيدرالي بصوره عامه يقال بانه العلاقه
ليست صحيه كثير وعشان هيك سالنا عن
المسافرين ماذا عن الشركات الطيران هل
استمعنا الى اي تصريحات رسميه او لا حتى
الان
حتى الان كان يعني التصريحات كلها كانت
تصب الى حول موضوع
تعطل الرحلات تاجيل الرحلات
لاسباب كما قالوا تقنيه وحفاظا على سلامه
المسافرين ولكن كما قلت ميسون الامر يعني
ما ما ما زال همم
غامضه
يعني لكن مع مرور الوقت مع مرور ساعات
القادمه والايام القادمه بالتاكيد سيكون
هناك
حصل في حاسوب معين هل هو هجوم سيبراني ادى
الى هذا العطل كما ذكرت في همم في السابقه
عاده هكذا هجمات تكون همم بتسمى بال-
هجمات الموزع او اختصارا بالانجليزيه التي
همم تغرق الخدوم او السعر الحاسوب بكم
كبير من الحركه ما يؤدي الى اا عرقلت هذا
هي الحواسيب وبالتالي الى تعطلها هل هذا
ما جرى طبعا حتى الان لا نعرف حتى الاداره
الامريكيه الرئيس ايضا قال انه لا يعرف لا
احد يعرف او ربما لا يعرف ولكن لا يجب ان
يتاكد قبل ان يوجهوا اصابتهم
الان ولكن نعم صحيح وفي تحقيقات جاريه
الان وسننتظر حتى يتم الاعلان عنها ولكن
حسين ابقى معي همم على الاقل علينا ان
نطرح السناريوهات المختلفه وخاصه انه هلا
لدينا معلومه عن اسم النظام التقنيه كابتن
طيار احمد نظام
ماذا يفعل هذا النظام
يزود الطائرات بالجو في اي تعديلات او تحت
تجديدات على ما يحدث على الساحه بالطيران
طبعا هذا له مراتب يكون شهري اسبوعي
اللحظه بيكون من خلال
[موسيقى]
المراحب الجوي او مراقبه طبعا هذا اللي هو
التناقل المعلومات بين المطارات بين الدول
اذا صار اي شيء ببعثوه
بحط على الشاشه انه هذا المطار مثلا
في حادث صار فيه همم الجو سيء زي هيك يعني
هل حدث في حالات معينه تابعتها كان في عطل
بهذا النظام تحديدا وهل تم الغاء كافه
الطيران او الرحلات عذرا همم وهل يحتاج
بالفعل الى الغاء ووقف كافه المطارات في
الولايات المتحده
في الطيران بشكل عام عندهم
حمايه الارواح اولا بعيدا العواطف وعلى
الاقتصاد عن السياسه اول شيء لهم اي اي
سوره الطيران في العالم ان السلامه الجويه
هلا اذا كان العطر همم لانه بدا في مطعم
وبدا يمتد او يتوسع همم لخوفا من ذلك انا
هذا التوقيت خوفا من التوسع السريع ويكون
حركه طيران قويه همم
وتوسع الاطل او في الطيران هلا بالنسبه
همم يعني في عندهم باكر كثير عندهم في
عندهم اكيد الدروس سلاح الجو
الخدمات العسكريه بيقدر يسيطر على الوضع
تماما بس لو في هجوم ما راح يحكم عنه لانه
بيثير الرعب في الشركات لذلك هم بيقلل
وبعدين لاحقان بعد تحقيقات راح بين كل شيء
خليني انقل نقاطك لضيفي ايضا معي من
القاهره دكتور محمد خاصه انك انت تميل
اكثر الى انه القضيه هي هجوم سبرانه
استمعت الى كابتن طيار احمد يقول انه
النقطه الرئيسيه بالنسبه لاي جهه هي حمايه
الارواح وهناك كان خوف اللي ان تتوسع او
يتوسع هذا العطل وبسرعه وبالتالي كان من
الواجب على الجميع ايقاف الرحلات ولو لم
يكن الوضع عطل فقط لكان سلاح الجو العسكري
قد تدخل ماذا تقول
هو طبعا يعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قوه عظمى دوله
كبيره تستطيع ان هي تستعيد الوضع في وقت
قليل جدا وعندما يخرج الرئيس الامريكي
ويقول انه لا يعرف اعتقد انه يعرف كل شيء
ولكنه لا يريد ان يقول رايي الا بعد
التحقيقات دي اول مره تحدث بتحدث في عالم
يموج الان بالاضطرابات الان بتستخدم اسلحه
جديده في العالم كله اسمها اسلحه الاضطراب
الفوضى الاضطراب ديستربانس اسلحه الاضطراب
الشامل يعني ما بنقولش اسلحه دمار شامل لا
ده اسلحه اضطراب اضطراب يعني لما يحدث مثل
هذا الحادث اليوم واا
وتعلق مثل تلك الرحلات الجويه في اكبر
دوله في العالم يقول الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اعتقد انه لا يوجد اضطراب اكثر
من ذلك هناك الحرب بين الولايات بين واشن
وموسكو بتقوم على ارض اوكرانيا وبالتالي
هو هناك ما اخذ كثيره من روسيا ضد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بدعمها
بالاسلحه او بالذخائر بل وتدريب الافراد
الاوكرانيين والجنود الاوكرانيين على
الاسلحه الحديثه مثل نظام باترون اعتقد ان
يعني حتى التحقيقات تستوفي وهذا الموقف
الغامض يتم اجلاله باعتقد انه سيكون هناك
شيء ما في الافق من خلال استخدام الاسلحه
الحديثه مثل هو عشان كده باقول برده ان
هناك حرب نفسيه عندما يخرج الرئيس همم جو
بايدن ويقول انه لا يعرف وانه عطله تقنيه
اعتقد بصدر الرساله الرساله الى الجانب
الاخر الى روسيا بان الموضوع هين و- وقوه
وقدره امريكا تستطيع ان تستعيد الوضع الى
ما كان عليه لكن ان يحدث هذا هو السؤال
الكريم
وكلامك هو همم السيناريو الحقيقي الذي حدث
ويحدث الان وتوسعه الرقعه
الافتراضيه اذا ما صح التعبير الحربيه ما
بين الغرب وتحديدا الولايات المتحده
وروسيا وصلت الى البناء التحتيه الامريكيه
شلل للمطارات كافه في الولايات المتحده هل
تعتقد من قراءاتك وهمم من خبرتك بانه الرد
سيكون ايضا هجوم سيبراني او اننا نتحدث
الان انه همم التوترات الجيو سياسيه قد
تؤدي الى توسعه الميدان على الارض ام انه
الحرب السيبرانيه هي همم ربما ستشتعل
وتبقى في هذا الاطار
اعتقد ان الرد سيكون من نفس العمل هناك
حرب سيبورانيه سيوجد هناك هجمات الكترونيه
اخرى ضد من تتحقق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بانه من قام باطلاق تلك الهجمات
لكن ان يتوسع على الارض ولا اعتقد ان لن
يسمح ووجود الردع ما يسمى بالردع النووي
بين الدولتين وبين حلف الناتو لن تستطيع
لن تكبر هذه الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه اكثر
من اوكرانيا ان لم يكن في القريب في مارس
او في الربيع القادم ان يتم الوصول الى
الحل الدبلوماسي والمفاوضات لانه هناك
خسائر كبيره ليس خسائر في روسيا وخسائر في
اوكرانيا فقط ولكن خسائر في العالم كله
وفي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي ايضا
اوروبا 500 مليار دولار هناك خسائر كانت
ممكن نتيجه همم الطاقه وعد كود الطاقه
وتوقف مصانع كل ذلك بيعاني العالم منه لن
تزداد دائره المعارك على الارض ولكن الحرب
الجديده الحرب السيبانيه الهجمات التي
يطلق عليها ما يسمى بالهجمات الالكترونيه
والتي تستخدم منذ فتره طويله وخاصه الدول
الكبرى هي من لديها مثل تلك
الاسلحه الحديثه والهجمات مثل الهجوم
السيبراني اللي احنا شوفنا باعتقد حتى
الان حتى تنظر نتائج التحقيقات ويتجلى هذا
الموقف الغامض اعتقد ان الحرب سيبرنيه لها
دور في ذلك وان اسلحه الاضطراب الشامل او
مجلس تربان سوربونس الان بتستخدم من خلال
حصار اقتصادي بيتم على روسيا وعلى دول همم
ضد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن خلال
استخدام الهجمات السيبرانيه في العالم كله
وليس في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فقط
ويمكن انا ضربت مثال انه في 2017 5000
جهاز طرد مركزي في مفاعل من الترانز
بايران تم ايقافه من خلال الهجمات
الاستيبرانيه اللي احنا بنسميها هناك
هجمات القوه الغاشمه وهناك هجمات اعياد
الميلاد وهناك هجمات الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهناك كثير من الهجمات التي تتبع التنصت
كما حدث في همم ما كيفك وكيف ان هناك 89
قتيل روسي نتيجه التنصت على اجهزه
الهواتف المحموله وبالتالي كل ذلك هذه
الحرب وهذه الهجمات الالكترونيه
وبعيدا عن قضيه ان كان سبراني او غير
سبراني خلينا نتحدث عن اخطر الهجمات التي
تخفيف اي اا اي مطار اي دوله واي دائره
طيران في العالم ما هي وهل الاسهل لها ان
تقول بان عطل فني توم مترهل بعد الشيء
ولكن قعد اصلحه او انه لا هجوم سيبراني
وبالتالي انا منفتحه على كافه الخيارات
كبيره عظمه امريكا
بحاولوا بقدر بامكان يبعدوا عنهم
او ضعف في اجهزتهم او الانظمه هم يتجهوا
اعاده الى العطل الفني هلا همم
ما وراء الكواليس ممكن يكون في هجوم
سبراني بس هم ما راح يعترفوا فيه الا بعد
التحقيقات هلا همم عيد الانتقام اذا وجدوا
النظام انه في هجوم سيفراني همم مثلا لو
حكينا روسيا روسيا ما عندها حركه الطيران
زي امريكا بسببها الان عليها مقاطع دوليه
حركه خفيفه اذا بكون رد يكون ممكن رد شيء
ثاني اما همم رد الدبلوماسي او رد همم من
خلال جبهات القتال يعني همم رد عسكري
سبراني همم
تفضلي لا كان بدي اسال لانه ذكرنا قبل
قليل لانه التاثيرات داخليه وايضا خارجيه
هل لنا ان نعرف اذا ما اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار الارقام التي تم الاعلان عنها
وهنا اتحدث عن تاجيل 4000 رحله الغاء 750
وان كان لا يشكل الا نسبه بسيطه من حجم
تحرك وحركه الطيران في الولايات المتحده
بصوره عامه ولكن لا شك بانه سيكون له
تاثير اين يتركز هذا التاثير اقتصاديا
كابتن طيار
نسبه حسن او حسن الطيران من اقتصاد امريكا
حوالي 5% يعني 1.3
هذا اليوم صباحا هلا هاي خسائر ماديه في
امريكا تقريبا
الشركات بتخسر شركات تامين التعويضات يعني
كبيره هلا بالنسبه
ااا متوقفه خلال فتره كورونا وبالتالي
القطاع نفسه متعب ومنهاك
وقفت بالكامل في امريكا بس كانت مقيده
يعني مقيده بس لفتره طويله بس اليوم احنا
بنحكي عن حوالي ساعتين فقط توقف الكامل
هلا في حركه الطيران كانت خفيفه كثير
الطائرات اللي
بالجو لتنزل والان عادوا الحركه
يعني همم تدريجيا لذلك مش توقف شلل كامل
وخصوصا على اوروبا لانه اكثر الطيران من
امريكا هو على اوروبا
الرئيس
التاثيرات طيران العالميين برده كبيره
تقريبا
اعود الى ضيفه دكتور محمد همم
يقال اذا عرف السبب بطل العجب جبتها لي
ايه عرف سبب ال- همم العطل وتم اصلاحه
ولكن اذا ما كان بغض النظر عن قضيه ان كان
هجوم سبراني او عطل فني هل الاصلاح بهذه
السرعه يعني بانه في حمايه كامله بغض
النظر عن سبب الرئيسي وراء ذلك
وهذا العبط لكن انا مع حضرتك الان باقول
ان نتيجه التحقيقات ستخرج بانه عطل تقني
عطل فني تم اصلحه لان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن تستطيع ان تقول
انهيه لم تعلن بغض النظر اذا كان استهداف
سيبراني او غير سيبراني هل خلال هذه
الفتره الزمنيه همم لاصلاحها تستطيع ان
تحني نفسها من ان لا يكون عطل جديد قادم
ان كان سبراني او غير سبراني او لا تحتاج
الى المزيد من الوقت همم
طبعا احنا نعلم ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اكبر قوه اكبر قوه عسكريه في
العالم واكبر وهي القوه العظمى وفي عالم
يعني بنقول عليها قطب واحد وبالتالي
تستطيع ان تقوم باصلاح اي عطل يترك لكن
سؤال هو نتيجه التحقيقات التي تتم لن تظهر
انها حرب سيبانيه حتى لا يكون هناك مواجهه
ما بين القوتين الاكبر الجيش الاول في
العالم طبقا لتقرير جلوبر فار باور همم
الذي همم يعني ظهر امس بيقول ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي القوه الاولى وروسيا
هو القوه الثانيه وبالتالي ان هناك الان
لن يتم ظهور انه هجوم سيبراني حتى لا تحدث
المواجهه في ظل هذا الاضطراب الذي يشمل
العالم كله لكن قدرتها وقوه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه استطاعت ان تعيد الوضع
الى مكان عليه خلال فتره بسيطه امن
الافراد هو مهم جدا ذلك الامن السيبراني
على درجه كبيره من القوه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي استطاع ان
يعرف الخطا ويصلح هذا الخطا اما انها تقول
ان ذلك عباره
ناتج عن هجمات الكترونيه من جهه ما اعتقد
ان ذلك لن يتم
اعود الى مراسل العربيه لانه لا اعلم ان
كان الولايات المتحده قادره على اخفاء اي
معلومات على مواطنيها ان كان فيما يتعلق
بهذا الاستهداف او غيره اعود لحسين همم من
مطار رونالد ريجن همم هل من سابقه بانه
الاداره الامريكيه لم تصارح مواطنيها باي
حادثه معينه كانت ارهابيه واخذت ذلك وتم
كشفها لاحقا هل هي قادره على فعل ذلك حسين
يعني لاسباب امنيه تتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي قد لا يخبر الامريكيون مباشره عن
حادثه حدثت ابو هجوم او وقعه ولكن نحن
نعرف ان في الولايات المتحده هناك حريه
اعلام و الصحافه
لديها السلطه كبيره وهي شرسه اذا صحح
الوسط تبحث عن الحقيقه دائما وتحاول
الحصول على سبق صحفي وهمم لدى نسيم عندما
تتحدث عن همم صحف الكبرى وسائل الاعلاميه
الكبرى في الولايات المتحده لديهم مصادر
يمكن كشف ايه اي همم تغطيه تقوم بها همم
كشف تغطيات تقوم بها الحكومه لهذا دائما
يفضل المسؤولون الامريكيون ان يكون هناك
ابلاغ او اشاره الى همم الراي العام
الامريكي كي لا يكون في وضع محرج همم
موضوع عن همم
او همم لعدم الكشف عنه اذا اذا تم مسود
يقول لاسباب هم يقولون بس باب تتعلق
بالامن القومي لديهم هذه الحجه ولكن ان ان
ان يخضع نعم ان يخدعوا المواطن الامريكي
هذا ما يحاول المسؤول لم يكون دائما ان
يتجنبوه لان لذلك تداعيات اذا تم كشفه واا
ثمان سيدفعه السياسيون اذا كشفوا واذا كشف
هناك تغطيه او انك خداع للراي العام
الى مطار دلس حيث ناديه البلبيسي مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك ناديه تفضل
اهلا بك ميسون بالفعل قبل قليل وصلت اكثر
من رحله خارجيه
الرحلات اتت من اديس ابابا ومن قطر تتحدث
مع بعض المسافرين قالوا بانهم لم يتاثروا
ربما لانه هيئه الطيران رفعت الحظر الساعه
9:00 بتوقيت واشنطن صباحا يعني قبل حوالي
ساعه همم وطبعا وصولهم لم يتاثر على كل
الاحوال اعتقد حسب المعلومات الاوليه كان
بامكان الطائرات ان تهبط لكن لا يمكن لها
ان تقلع وبالتالي نستطيع ان نقول بانه
مطار دلس على فكره هو من اكبر المطارات
الذي يخدم العاصمه واشنطن فيه الرحلات
الدوليه بالتحديد مطار ريجن حيث يتواجد
حسين هو مطار محلي داخلي لكن هنا الطائرات
التي تاتي من الخارج تهبط بسلام بدون اي
دون اي مشاكل
اذا كان من امكانيه تحريك الكاميرا اللي
نشاهد الحركه داخل همم المطار ويمكنك اه
نحنا بالطابقه
هناك طابقين ميسون بس اسمحي لي اشرح هذه
الجزئيه همم وصول
وصول المسافرين هو بالطابق الاول لا
نستطيع ان نصور من هناك لكن نحن في الطابق
الثاني هنا حيث يتم الاقلاع وليس الوصول
طبعا خلفي كانت قبل قليل الطائرات التي
كانت تهبط همم لكن الاشخاص الذين تحدث
عنهم بطابق الاول استطيع ربما سنحاول مع
المسؤولين في المطار ان في النشره القادمه
ان نكون من الطابق الاول اذا سمح لنا لكن
على كل الاحوال استطيع ان اقول بانه الان
همم عمليه همم الاقلاع الهبوط تتم بشكل
سلس وبسلام لكن هذا لا يعني عمليات تاخير
لساعات طويله خصوصا في الرحلات الداخليه
حوالي اربعه الاف رحله تم- تعطيلها بسبب
هذا الخلل عاده عن ذلك طبعا اذا تحدثنا عن
الجزء الذي يتعلق بالسلامه والامان هو
اجراء احترازي قامت بهيئه الطيران ال او
هيئه الملاحه بشكل سريع حتى تمنع اي حوادث
اي تصادم او اي حادث ممكن ان يؤدي الى
مخاطر في الارواح او الى ما شابه لا لكن
الخطر او ربما الازمه السياسيه ستتفاقم
قبل قليل المسؤولين في في الكونغرس طبعا
طالبوا بجلسات استماع لوزير المواصلات في
بوتجاج وغيره لمعرفه هل هو النظام قديم في
المطارات الامريكيه لم يحدث حتى الان
لماذا يحدث هذا الخلل وبهذا الحجم يعني
حدث بالسابق لكن ليس على ماذا كل الولايات
المتحده يعني كل الرحلات يتم تعطيلها
وخصوصا كانت في البدايه بالساحل الشرقي
هنا في ولايه فرجينيا وفي نيويورك وفي
غيرها هناك مساءله اكيد وهناك همم اكثر من
جلسه تتوقع في الكونجرس كيف يمكن تفادي
هذه الخسائر الماديه الكبيره نتحدث طبعا
عن احداث مشابهه بعد ازمه كورونا ازمه
الطيران وغيرها لكن لم نرى ما رايته بهذا
الحجم بكل الولايات المتحده وبالتالي على
الاقل بايضا قال قبل قليل بانه لا يعرف
السبب اسمع بعد ان يكون هناك هجوم سيبراني
لكن على الاقل هناك خلل فني كما ذكرت على
مدى ان نشري ميسون استبعاد للهجوم
السبراني هذه كافه التصريحات الموجوده حتى
الان ااه ناديه ولكن اسمحي لي ان اسال من
تعاطي مع هذه الازمه ليعطينا اشارات على
الاقل عن ان كان هناك مخاوف على الاقل من
ان يكون العمل ارهابي نحن نتحدث عن اداره
الطيران الفدرالي ومن ايضا
تتحدث عن وزير الاتصالات
المواصلات عفوا في بوداجاج نتحدث عن
الرئيس بايرن يعني الرئيس بايرن عاده سولا
قبل قليل وهو في طريقه الى مستشفى والتريد
اذا كان بالفعل يعرف السبب قال انه لا
يعرف السبب لكنه يستبعد العطل الهجوم
السيبراني ايضا كريم جون بير المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض استبعدت هذا وبالتالي
عاده يعني لدى المسؤولين الامريكيين
التقييم الاولي اذا كان بالفعل هناك هجوم
ارهاب او هجوم سيفراني او الكتروني
يعرفونه بمجرد يعني التحليل الاولي حتى
الان لا يوجد هناك اي مؤشرات تشير الى ذلك
يبدو انه بالفعل الخطا فني ومن هنا جاءت
السرعه برفعه الحضري يعني همم الموضوع بدا
يتفاعل في الساعه السابعه مساء همم هيئه
الملاحه قالت همم
يعني للمسافرين لشركات الطيران بنات سترفع
الحظر الساعه 9:00 مساءا يعني ده ساعتين
هذا يعني بانه هجوم سبراني عاده همم
الهجوم السبرانيه اخذ وقت اطول
ويعطل كل منحى ال ال النظام الالكتروني
المتعلق بالسفر همم لذا اعتقد بانه نرى
الان عوده طبيعيه لربما السفر لا اعرف اذا
كان احمد اذا كان في امكانيه ان نحول
الكاميرا على همم بسرعه لو سمحت
خلال هذه الدقيقه عن
محيطك وبنفس الوقت الاعلام هل من غضب او
لا باختصار عندك دقيقه
اه اوكي بشكل سريع عوده الحياه الطبيعيه
الى كل الى مطار دالاس ايضا في مطار
اتلانتا ومطار نيويورك حسب ما اعرف
بالنسبه لي هل هناك غضب الولايات المتحده
متعوده كما تعرفين ميسون هي قاره يعني نعم
نعم
ناديه البلبيسي شكرا جزيلا لك من مطار دلس
اشكر مراسل العربيه من رونالدو
حسين الطود وايضا الضيوفي من تورنتو
الكابتن الطيار احمد العجارمه الخبير طبعا
من القاهره الدكتور محمد الشهاوي خبير
الامن السيبراني شكرا لمتابعه على التغطيه
مستمره المشاهديننا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]